this is the the D bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum greetings of
peace peace be upon you and we are
coming to you again another episode of
the Deen show every week same time same
channel it's a very exciting topic today
with a very exciting guest my next guest
dr. Lawrence Brown is gonna come out in
a second it's somebody who has a DD
doctor and divinity also has a PhD in
religious studies he used to be an
atheist and was trying very hard to be a
Christian but he ended up following the
way of Jesus the way of Moses the way of
Noah the way of Abraham the way of all
the prophets Islam because Islam simply
means to acquire peace by submitting
yourself entirely to the owner peace the
one God now our next topic dr. Brown is
going to be giving us the top five
reasons why Jesus peace be upon him
we've covered in previous shows the top
reasons why he's not the begotten Son of
God why he's not the son of God and now
we're gonna be covering dr. Brown's top
5 reasons why Jesus is not divine at all
God is God Jesus is Jesus Jesus was a
mighty messenger never did he say he was
God never did he claim to be God and
we're gonna be giving you the facts not
fiction on today's show sit tight
this is the things of the teacher
this is the thing is the thing this is
the thing
tell I'm making peace be with you
welcome Sam and to you you know it I
know it they don't know it you know
Abraham Moses Jesus Christ and the last
and final master part Muhammad peace be
upon him they used this greeting I
didn't say what's up guy they said
please be on to you is this fact or
fiction no this is this is the truth
that's one fact that fact or fiction
that many people they do get a little
bit stressed out and didn't do childish
things
and they'll say ignorant things I think
because of this next topic we're about
to cover so we don't want to hurt
nobody's feelings salam says I shall
love all mankind and from the beginning
we know that everyone is born in
original goodness with a fresh clean
page so we want the best for everybody
but just like that computer you get it
out the box it gets a virus here there
so I think some things that have crept
into the minds of people a lot of these
false ideas and this is one of them and
Jesus is divine he has some kind of
divine status that he's co-equal to God
this is definitely fiction that fact
that's why we brought someone who is
credible someone who many consider a
Christian scholar to come on and to
discuss this issue are you ready I'm
ready
but I have to say I have to say you just
touched on something you said it's
something that has crept into people's
thoughts this isn't a concept that has
crept into people's thoughts this is a
concept that crept into church Canon I
mean this crept into an established
religion which went around the world
which has been spreading this viewpoint
for more than a thousand years almost
you know going on 2,000 years so it it
is it is critical to address this issue
very critical and I think this is why
you know you have people who get angry
and you know we bring the evidence we
don't place so they'll make up childish
claims and they'll start calling Muslims
terrorists not all terrorists are Muslim
but all Muslims are terrorists all this
you know just false rhetoric you know
and we know that Islam has nothing Aslam
has nothing to do with killing innocent
men women and children we want peace we
started to show with peace and we want
people to have peace they first got to
have peace with their Creator you know
it's funny that you should say that
because actually I was thinking just
before this show we didn't talk about
this this wasn't planned but I
thinking just before the show but it was
funny how we start each of these shows
with the greeting of peace and with the
discussion of this on a previous episode
I was discussing how Jesus Christ taught
his disciples to offer the greeting of
peace to one another and then he set the
example by doing it himself offering the
greeting of peace and you know here we
are talking about peace peace peace and
yet other people are talking about
Muslims as terrorists you know we can't
be completely insensitive we understand
where they're coming from we understand
about 9/11 we understand about the
subway bombings in England okay but we
also we can't forget that terrorism
you know crimes in general crimes have
been perpetuated by people from all
walks of life from all institutions and
you can't just you just can't put a
pigeon hole and say okay we agree not
all Muslims are terrorists but pretty
much all terrorists are Muslims you know
I look back recently over the FBI
statistics which are listed on the
internet and it shows that over the past
well since I believe it was since 1980
okay so we're talking about a catalog
over a significant period of time when
you look at the number of terrorist acts
committed on the United States and soil
only six percent of them were carried
out by Muslims only six percent six
percent now you've got you've got
anti-abortion terrorists you've got tax
protester terrorists you've got
right-wing terrorists you've got white
supremacist terrorists you have you have
a large lists of groups and even those
who have no group affiliation committing
acts of terrorism and nobody is standing
up and saying you know we we understand
that all Southern Baptists are not
terrorists but all abortion clinic
our Southern Baptist nobody says that
because the media focus is not on that
number one and number two it's not true
okay it's just not true and in the same
way the media focus right now is to take
anything that you know anything that
puts the Muslims in the in the spotlight
and blow it up to make it look normal
make it look normal for the Muslims this
is and this is you know I mean every
time I see this I almost want to just
like grab a television and say you know
grow up
I mean grow up see the world the way it
really is there are good people and
there are bad people in pretty much
every walk of life in every country you
know it's like equal rights um you know
movement you know no matter what race
color creed religion you know Society
whatever there are good and bad people
in all walks of life we as Muslims we
denounce terrorism it's a crime we
recognize that does that mean that there
are not Muslims who are terrorists of
course not
there are okay and they are criminals
and we recognize them as criminals and
we would we would be the first to put
them in prison ourselves you go to some
of country's Muslim countries and you
find out that's exactly what they're
doing you know in Saudi Arabia and
Indonesia the most of the Muslims
recognize those who are upon deviant
ideology those who are at risk of
terrorism and they're put in jail yeah
so that we got to clear at one point and
hopefully now that that sincere
individual can see past all the anti
Islamophobia and whatever other ideas
have been put out there that you know
associate Islam Muslims of terrorism you
explain this quite well but let's get
back to the main issue at hand those top
five reasons why Jesus was beloved to
our heart
we're not the Antichrist we love Jesus
no Muslim no Muslim suv's in Jesus let's
start with number five we got to get
through all of these in this show okay
meat to us number five to begin with
Jesus Christ himself denied divinity in
John 14 28 he's quoted as having said my
father is greater than I John 5:19 the
son can do
thing of himself John 8:28 I do nothing
of myself but as the father taught me
you can you can go down a long list I've
just given you three quotes but there's
actually a very very long list of
passages in which Jesus Christ showed
himself as subject it to God
Luke 4:8 you shall worship the Lord your
God and him only you shall serve him
only you shall serve you know if ever
there were a time for Jesus Christ who
have said you shall worship Me
this could have been it but what did he
say you shall worship the Lord your God
and him only your shelter so these these
are a number of a very very long list of
passages in the Bible in which Jesus
Christ denies divinity shows himself as
being subjugate to God and we just not
partner with God but subjugate not at
all a partner with God mighty messenger
of God and we're gonna continue on with
dr. Brown's five top reasons how Jesus
could not was not never was never
claimed to be any co-equal or of any
divine status with God the Creator the
one God we'll be right back with the
rest of the four here on the Dean show
Islam prohibits killing of innocent
human beings human life is precious
there always be someone that will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say something positive awesome just
hold onto the Rope of Allah everything
in this universe can rely I need a last
minute the Quran says don't kill women
don't kill children don't kill the old
people don't attack the civilians this
is what the Prophet Muhammad told if
you're famous you know law so that the
Prophet or solid never ever start a war
against
I am Not Afraid
you
why is our news media foaming at the
mouth when it comes to stories about
Islamic terrorists but not white guy
terrorists is that because Muslims are a
bigger threat in fact between 1980 and
2005 94 % of all the attempted or
successful terrorist attacks on US soil
were not carried out by Islamic radicals
but instead by non-muslims mostly white
guys so then why the obsession back here
in the D show with the top 5 with dr.
Brown wasting no time let's go to number
4 take it away dr. Brown ok well we just
talked about was how Jesus Christ denied
divinity now let's talk about what he
affirmed he affirmed his humanity he
affirmed that he was a prophet he
affirmed that he was a man read mark 6
for Matthew 13 57 Luke 13 33 again these
are only three passages of a list of
passages which defined Jesus Christ as a
man and as a prophet okay so on one hand
item number five he denies divinity item
number four he affirms his humanity he
affirms his prophethood that's number
four that's number four let's keep going
let's keep going number three number
three the only New Testament verse the
only New Testament verse to teach the
Incarnation is 1 Timothy 3:16 go look it
up in this verse you will find it
clearly states in the Bible 1 Timothy
3:16 it clearly states God was manifest
in the flesh well well that's it God was
manifest in the flesh that's the proof
right there right Jesus must have been
divine
well there's only one problem the
problem is that as with other verses we
have previously discussed you will find
that in your English translation you
will find that in virtually any
translation you read anywhere in the
world but I'll tell you where you will
not find it you will not find it in the
original manuscripts from which the
Bible was translated the reason why and
this is brilliant
exposed by Bart Dearman in his writings
he's not the only scholar to have
written about it this has been written
about since the time of Sir Isaac Newton
who exposed it in one of his letters but
could not talk about it because to talk
about it in his time would have brought
condemnation by the church but since the
time of Sir Isaac Newton this has been
exposed what has been exposed what has
been exposed is that the scribes took
the word who and changed it to the word
God the original passage spoke of Jesus
Christ who was manifest in the flesh
but now when you read it it says God was
manifest in the flesh okay that's that's
because why that's because we're reading
our translations and we are trusting the
people who who took the manuscripts
which were copied by the scribes and the
scribes introduced errors into the
manuscripts and then carried them
forward okay but we but we now have the
you know the oldest manuscripts the
codex fine Atticus the kotas excuse me
the codex arsine Atticus and the codex
Vaticanus
which are the the oldest manuscripts
that we have and from these we can learn
that this passage originally was
speaking of Christ who was manifest in
the flesh not God who is manifest in the
flesh that's number three that's number
three let's keep moving along number
number two to number two is just common
sensical okay God is all-knowing God is
all-powerful God doesn't need anything
right think about it if God needed
something and God wouldn't be God
because he would be relying or dependent
upon something else to satisfy his needs
so God cannot need anything God is
all-powerful he's all sufficient and yet
throughout the Bible we read about
Jesus's humanity and his
NEADS I mean he was born he was suckled
at the breast of his mother he he ate he
drank he slept when it came to items of
worship I mean he made ablution he
prayed he fasted he made pilgrimage all
of these things reveal his humanity ok
and it reveals something else and
reveals that he was dependent upon
something when he was a baby he was
dependent upon his mother ok can you
imagine Jesus being God being dependent
upon an element of his own creation I
mean he needed to find food he needed to
find drink he couldn't he he slept
why because sleep would overcome a human
being sleep does not overcome God he
prayed why if you are God and you have
the ability to do anything you want
because you're all-powerful what is the
purpose of prayer to yourself so as I
said number two is just kind of common
sensical here you have a man whose
humanity is is well documented showing
that he was dependent upon God he had
needs and this is not Dudley this these
are the characteristics of a man not a
God now before we go on to the number
one reason of the top 5 your top 5 dr.
Brown's top 5 reasons why Jesus peace be
upon him this mighty messenger who we
love and revere no Melissa Mirza Muslim
unless he believes in Jesus some I be
hearing his for the first time you're
like wow these people really are not the
Antichrist they love Jesus and we feel
we follow him more than a lot of
Christians and tell us now I've had the
wonderful opportunity to interview other
Christian scholars former crew people
who were Christians like dr. Gerald
Dirk's finished from Harvard Divinity
School also assisted by the name of
Donnell she finished seminary school got
her master's and others and they all
came to a point where they you know in
seminary school you go deeper into the
text you study the history and they see
that oh certain things unfolding that
the layman doesn't see now they have to
come to a to a point
of no return do they continue further or
sincerity how can I preach teach
something that you know these verses are
taken out here
these are concocted it doesn't make
sense you know and it's confusion so
they back away what is your opinion do
many of the people who go to the
seminary school big business other
personal interests you might lose your
status
you might not be able to hang out with
some of the elite there are many sincere
people out there I'm sure or some people
just get so emotional and wrapped up and
they're not using the logic and the
tools that God gave us what do you think
about this yeah no actually Bharti
Airman speaks about this in one of his
books how he does he finds it just yeah
he found it disappointing that everybody
goes through seminary school and they
learn these things but when they come
out they just go back to toeing the line
of whatever denomination they're
following and that does seem to be the
common experience in my interactions and
my interfaith interactions with other
priests ministers and you know I
shouldn't say other because I'm not a
priest or a minister but interactions
with priests ministers and so on when I
bring up these points they know these
points before I have discussed they know
oh no they they know them they and and
they were raised upon these pieces of
information in their own teaching but
because these pieces of information
conflicted with their own doctrine they
went with doctrine over you know over
what made sense over the evidence
basically most in my experience most
people teach the most people treat these
discussions like religious turf wars
rather than a sincere effort to get to
the truth you know in Islam we submit to
God that means we submit to the truth
okay and one of the things we say is we
openly admit if Jesus Christ were the
son of the God we would be the first to
worship we would be the first to worship
Him because we're not trying to defend
our position we are upon an endless
search for
the truth and wherever we find that
truth that's what we're going to go with
but in my experience that's not the
common opinion the common opinion is
people are looking for any evidence that
supports their position when they
encounter evidence contrary to their
beliefs even though it doesn't matter
how strong that evidence is they just
push it aside yeah yeah now before we go
to break we give the number one reason
just one more point if you can comment
on this we know that you know we
wouldn't accept this in our daily lives
we really would get an attorney we draw
up a contract if there's anything that's
taken out from here if something is
crossed out something doesn't make sense
we won't sign it we won't put our name
on it but many of these books you know
the Met Gospel of Matthew Mark Luke and
John you mentioned in a previous show
that no credible scholar would say that
these are from the disciples these are
anonymous books and so are many of the
other Gospels so people rest their whole
salvation on it anonymous books that we
don't even know who the authors are
would this even stand up in court
what a court case can with no witnesses
I mean certainly we can discuss that on
another show probably yeah because the
discussion of the Bible is a very long
one but yes all four of the Gospels were
anonymous none of them were signed none
of them were attributed to a particular
author biblical scholars agree that
Matthew Mark Luke and John probably did
not write Matthew Mark Luke and John
they were authored by other personages
who were gifted in Greek but they were
not the earthly disciples of Jesus and
they were they were not even the people
to whom they were attributed because
Matthew Mark Luke and John
these were not you know most of them
were not even disciples but this is a
long discussion long de sousa long
suction but these are just mind boggling
facts not fiction
that many people don't know about and
that's what we're here to discuss and we
want the best for everybody we'll be
right back with the number one reason
why Jesus peace be upon him it is not
God never claimed to be God has no
divine status with God is not co-equal
to God God is God Jesus is Jesus we're
right back here in a Deen show I don't
say the people I used to be a Christian
I still carry the values and principles
of loving Jesus Christ and perhaps maybe
more than even scriptures so I think I
got the best out of Christianity by
becoming Muslim without drinking a sip
of alcohol this is the same thing it's
not an obstacle it's not something to
cause people to get completely desperate
and start stopping living their lives no
it should be a motivation it's only one
life that you're gonna be living so you
better do it for last channel Italia
I am Not Afraid I am not afraid to stand
alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone if I'm honest I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am Not Afraid
back on the Dean show we're giving you
the top five reason dr. Brown's top five
reasons why Jesus peace be upon him is
not co-equal to God is not divine of any
status close to God other than a
Messenger of God let us continue in four
five four three two and the number one
reason dr. Brown
take it away okay number one reason is
that in the Bible we don't find any
evidence to support Jesus being divine
now a lot of people have thrown out a
lot of reasons that they consider to be
evidence let me just go through those
number one Jesus performed miracles he
cured the blind he healed the lepers he
raised the dead they all say okay he
performed these great miracles therefore
he must be divine then again in the
Bible we have Elijah doing all of these
same things we have a number of prophets
doing performing a number of miracles
and the you know so you have to you have
to either invite all of them to the
party you have to say performing
miracles means that you are divine
therefore all of these prophets are
divine because they all performed
miracles or you have to recognize that
this is not a sign of divinity that the
prophets were were performing miracles
by the power of God not by any power of
their own second issue some people say
well Jesus was divine because he was the
Savior well the word translated to
Savior is spelled Y a sha it has
encountered 207 times in the Old
Testament
it's encountered with a hood with sham
GaN with Gideon with with many
individuals okay for whom it's not
translated Savior with Jesus Christ is
translated Savior but the word that is
translated Savior is count is
encountered with many individuals
selectively translation translating it
to Savior in the case of Jesus Christ
and translating a shout to a different
word for other individuals makes you
think that Jesus Christ was the only one
called Savior the fact of the matter is
that that's only true in your
translation that's not true in the
foundational manuscripts so again this
doesn't hold any weight
John 8:58 records Jesus as having said I
am Exodus 3:14 records God as having
said I am so some people say Jesus said
I am God says I am therefore Jesus is
God know why because in John 8:58 the
word is emaii IMI it stated 152 times in
the in the Bible okay only one time is
it capitalized and that's when when it's
attributed to to Jesus alright the other
151 times it's not capitalized why is
that again selective translation another
point is that the word attributed to
Jesus was this IIM ie me in Exodus 3:14
the word attributed to God was haya or
ho owned so you can't equate evening
with haya or with holon these are
different words this is so well
recognized the Revised Standard Version
New Revised Standard Version new and
cyclin they have all reduced the
capitalization and you cannot find
support for this in their Bibles because
they're upstanding according to their
scripture and they recognize it now
there are many other doctrines such as
Jesus being the right-hand man the the
quotation that says the Lord I am the
first and I and the last beside me there
is no God
negates that in addition we know that in
Genesis 5:24 Enoch walked with God so if
Jesus was the right-hand man according
to mark 1619 and according to Genesis
5:24 Enoch walked with God what does
that make him forget forgiveness of sins
according to the Bible Jesus forgave
sins but according to John 5:30
Jesus said I of myself can do nothing so
was he forgiving sins or was he passing
on God's forgiveness of sins Jesus was
called Lord so is Abraham so is Moses
Moses was called Elohim - Aaron Elohim
means God in the Bible Moses was
recognized as God judges were recognized
as God's angels were recognized as
guides prophets were all of these were
described by the same word the same word
Elohim which was attributed to God okay
so you you have you have to eat embrace
the inconsistency or you have to
recognize that you are being selective
in how you apply the terminology saying
I want to believe that Jesus Christ is
God so we'll take this word and we'll
translate it in a way that makes him
look like God but with everybody else
that this word is applied to we'll we'll
write it in a different way this is not
this is not honesty this is this is not
being faithful to the scripture now in
the same way there are many other
evidences that we can cite but the point
is this each evidence has to bring
something to the table to contribute to
the the doctrine if it's going to carry
any weight okay but if each evidence
carries no weight whatsoever
a thousand evidences still adds up to
zero you still get a goose egg you still
roll a doughnut
you cannot float a raft made out of a
hundred rocks because none of those
rocks bring any boolean C okay you
cannot win a court case over a thousand
testimonials if none of those
testimonials brings any truth to the
matter to support to support your case
and it's the same it's the same here
every single one of these claims to
support the divinity of Jesus is easily
refuted so easily refuted that again it
just becomes common sensical you just
realize that none of these evidences
brings any weight to the argument so
number one fact of the matter in the
Bible there is no evidence to support
the doctrine of the divinity of Jesus
Christ there is a lot of information
it's made quite simple to understand is
there anything we're gonna single that
we're out of time look one just another
in another minute or anything you want
to add to this just I think everybody
else out there knows the arguments some
people say Jesus Christ was filled with
the Holy Spirit but then again so were
Peter Steven Barnabas Elizabeth
Zachariah John the Baptist was filled
with the Holy Spirit from the womb so if
that makes you divine where do they
factor into this some people say
that some of the followers worshipped
Jesus Christ the word was prosecuted
mean means bowed down the Bible also
describes a slave by the same word to
his master Abigail to David
Cornelius to Peter a Sunnah might woman
to Elijah so again what does this make
them if bowing down to somebody makes
them God you have to you have to factor
in the slave master David Peter Elijah
you know and say that all these people
were divine as well the resurrection
okay this is kind of like the last thing
people say well Jesus was resurrected
that makes it a god
look check out the history do me a favor
take the four Gospels line them up from
the alleged crucifixion and look how
consistent they are one gospel says his
last words were it is finished another
gospel says his last words were into
your hands I commend my spirit you can't
have it both ways these are mutually
exclusive one says these are the last
words the other says these are the last
words and they are different Matthew
records an earthquake Matthew records an
angel the other three Gospels are silent
how do you miss an earthquake and an
angel in in Palestine in that period
where nothing else is going on how do
you miss an earthquake an angel much
less three Gospel writers missing it and
one recording it at the tomb it records
I mean you just look at it line up the
Gospels and look I mean one gospel says
that when that when they went to the
tomb to you know to see Jesus there was
a man another gospel says an angel
another gospel says two men another
gospel says two angels one gospel says
they were outside one gospel says they
were inside one gospel says that they
were at the head of where he was laying
ones the one gospel says different yeah
there is no consistency in the stories
and if there's no consistency of the
stories you would not accept this as a
standard of reliability in any other
testimonial why do you accept it in the
Bible so bottom line we can't even trust
we can't even trust the biblical
narratives in relation to the
resurrection so we can't hold it up as
evidence these are the top five that's
these are the top five that that's the
last of the evidence
that I would cite that can be easily
refuted we got a few seconds how could
people get a hold of you read some of
your books and if they want to dialogue
with you about this topic further well
you'll find this information and a whole
lot more on my website and my articles
in my books my website is level truth
calm and eighth scroll calm both of
those are just two words no spaces no
underscores just level truth calm eighth
scroll com we started with peace we end
with peace peace be unto you thank you
very much for being with me God Almighty
a lot of words and you thank you and
there you have it made simple Tumnus and
lucid clear logical rational five of the
top reasons why Jesus is not divine by
doctor of divinity dr. Brown
if you like what we had to say and you
want to learn more what we believe about
geez what of the mightiest messengers of
God just like Abraham Moses no one the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
upon Muhammad peace be upon him they all
call people to submit and to surrender
not to themselves not to angels Saints
not to men and monkeys but to the one
God who created this whole universe and
everything in it and we have the
verbatim Word of God the Quran which is
preserved memorized by millions a living
miracle called the 1-800 number on the
screen to get you a free copy today
we'll see you next time peace be unto
you